ja nochmal wie kommen zur ersten
vorlesung im neuen jahr heute steht das
thema ethik der digitalität im zentrum
und zwar der dritte teil dieser thematik
der ethik oben rechts mache ich den link
zur vorherigen sitzung hinein in der wir
uns mit der ethik von künstlicher
intelligenz befasst haben das ist auch
das thema was sich im heutigen plan
zunächst noch mal kurz wiederholen werde
dann gehen wir weiter zu ethik der
digitalität dem eigentlichen thema der
heutigen sitzung zur ethik des
virtuellen raumes auf basis unserer
vorherigen überlegung und dann gibt es
am schluss einen ausblick auf die
nächste sitzung in der die ästhetik der
digitalität im zentrum stehen soll jetzt
habe erst der rückblick zur letzten
sitzung tätig der künstlichen
intelligenz
ich hatte argumentiert vielleicht
erinnern sie sich noch dass eine ethik
der künstlich dilligence vorher bevor es
eigentlich um die eigentlichen fragen
geht einige fragen klären muss das
betrifft auch eine ethik der digitalität
im allgemeinen nämlich ist künstliche
intelligenz ein zu tippt kann künstliche
intelligenz handeln besitzt künstliche
intelligenz intentional i tät als
geistige gericht zeit auf etwas ist
künstliche intelligenz autonom das ist
vielleicht die entscheidende frage ja
und hier gibt es jetzt schon eure
forschung dazu unter anderem das oxford
händler auf fx auf real und ich möchte
hier noch mal ein zitat bringen ich
werde jetzt nicht ganz vorlesen hier
geht es jetzt nur darum dass der autor
die autoren dieses artikels sagen dass
künstliche intelligenz alle bisherigen
begriffe vielleicht nicht ganz ändern
aber doch in neues verhältnis ein wehr
also diese entwicklungen der
digitalisierung die digitalität die ist
so
herausfordernd für die philosophie dass
wir hier doch uns über die bisherigen
begriffe gedanken machen müssen ob die
eins zu eins übertragen werden können
vom analogen auf den digitalen raum auch
mit blick auf eine ethik ich stimme den
autor zu ich glaube auch dass wir die
begriffe noch mal neu und kritisch
reflektieren müssen und auch neue
begriffe prägen müssen zumindest die
bisherigen begriffe kritisch betrachten
müssen das ist alles sehr zu empfehlen
dieses oxford handbook of ethics of real
und jetzt kann man natürlich noch weiter
sich gedanken dazu machen zum einen bis
es unbestritten dass künstliche
intelligenzen mehr teil unserer
lebenswelt wird und jetzt kann man sich
fragen ist der begriff der
mensch-maschine-interaktion der dafür
bislang verwendet wurde ist er überhaupt
noch angemessen
um diese lebenswichtige bedeutung von
künstlicher intelligenz zu beschreiben
oder müssen wir nicht einen anderen
begriff ins spiel bringen ich glaube
dafür argumentiert dass wir künstlich
intelligente nicht im sinne eines
subjekts oder objekts verstehen sollten
sondern ihren auf den prozess oder die
intelligenz leistung reflektieren
sollten die mit künstliche intelligenz
einhergeht warum
diese intelligenz leistung sich immer
mehr hinzu lebenswelt integrieren lässt
und vernetzt wird oder fast schon
verspielt ist mit anderen operationen
oder intelligenz leistungen von uns
menschen also man kann sie sich wie
erweiterungen vorstellen aber auch die
sind diese metapher der erweiterung eine
prothese halte ich nicht für ganz
angemessen ich möchte dafür
argumentieren das ganze im rahmen des
begriffs der inter objektivität zu
verstehen also im sinne dieser
vernetzung von verschiedenen ligen sly
stone die vernetzung scheint sie scheint
mir ganz wichtig zu sein auch diese
lebensweltlich integration
das kann man sich fragen ob die künstler
intelligenz zur erweiterung des
wirtschaftsraums eintritt als ob
künstliche intelligenz im sinne
virtuelle realität zu riesige diskutiert
haben nach oben rechts noch mal ein link
zur sitzung über virtuelle realität
bleibt ob wir sie anhand dieses
paradigmas angemessen zu stehen können
das ist die entscheidende frage
ich glaube wir können jetzt auch wenn
wir hier ohne auch einige dinge vorher
tun müssen aber ich glaube wir können
künste intelligenz so verstehen dass wir
sie als virtuelle realität
auffassen können wie genau das werde ich
noch genauer sagen jedenfalls geht es
mir erst mal die vernetzung von
menschlichen operationen und künstlicher
intelligenz und zwar ist der grund der
das künstliche intelligenz die
neuronalen netze die wir behandelt
hatten ich mache da auch noch mal oben
rechts links zu der sitzung dass die man
mit gewaltigen datenmengen operieren und
diese datenmengen gehen immer auch
menschliche leistung mit 1 das heißt wir
sind nie ganz zu trennen von künstlichen
intelligenz in ihren prozessen diese
menschlichen und ki prozesse die
interferieren könnte man auch sagen also
die sind vernetzt wenn auch auf eine so
komplexe art dass ich am ende subjekt
und objekt objekt jetzt kann nicht mehr
wirklich voneinander unterscheiden
lassen das heißt die menschlichen
leistungen sind nicht mehr
identifizierbar
menschliche leistung und camille
leistung interferieren inter objektiv
und inter objektivität das war auch ein
wichtiger begriff den ich versucht hat
sich hier zu profilieren in der
objektivität bedeuten kontext von
gründen und zielen der durch die
künstliche intelligenz weiter vernetzt
und idealerweise verstärkt das internet
ist hier weniger dann am ende ein
letzter information als ein netz der
gründe und gründe sind immer auch
kognitiv zu verstehen das heißt medial
fall wird unser informationsnetz so
dicht dass wir nicht nur mehr
informationen bekommen sind aber immer
mehr gründe bekommen wird das eine oder
das andere als es wird man
nachvollziehbare und verständlicher das
ist eben auch mit künste intelligenz zu
verstehen nicht immer nur informations
vergrößerung das ist ja nun quantitative
dimension ich glaube auch dass es eine
qualitative dimension gibt die mit
künstlichen intelligenz ins spiel kommen
im center objektivität dennoch muss man
hier ein schrecken zeigen dass günstige
genc immer von außen ein ziel vorgesetzt
bekommen muss das heißt sie bestimmt nie
von sich aus was sie jetzt tun soll
zumindest noch nicht ich glaube auch
dass es prinzipiell nicht möglich ist
der künstliche intelligenzen müssen
immer von außen also hypothetisch ein
ziel vorgesetzt bekommen sind deswegen
nur hypothetisch autonom also nur unter
der bedingung eines vorgesetzten zieles
das ist aber nicht weiter tragisch weil
diese hypothetische intelligentes eben
erlaubt künstliche intelligenz
anzubinden anzuschließen an unsere
intelligenz und so mehr noch als ein
bloßes hilfsmittel als ein inter
objektiver kontext der gründe gebraucht
werden kann das ist also meine
auffassung fertig der künste intelligenz
ethik jetzt nicht nur im strengen
moralischen sinne zu verstehen seine
idee im sinne des epos als der city der
lebenswelt zu verstehen künstlich
intelligente immer mehr teil unserer
lebenswelt ich kann mir es nicht nur
eine gefahr oder sowas das ist auch noch
ein problem aber tickets im sinne der
lebensweltlichen realität der vernetzung
scheint mir ganz wichtig zu sagen jetzt
noch ein paar probleme die
verantwortungs zuschreibung wird durch
cani mal schwieriger wer trägt denn
jetzt die verantwortung der hersteller
die nutzer oder die künstlerin selbst es
gibt einige philosophen und für so viel
luciano für beide ist einer der
argumentiert dass künstliche intelligenz
selbst verantwortlich betrachtet werden
kann als verantwortlich angesehen werden
kann willkommen am ende der heutigen
vorleser auf floridis these der dann
sogar argumentiert es gibt ein künstlich
böses
fischer boel
künstliche intelligenz zutrifft also
kann böse handeln ist eine starke these
die müssen wir diskutieren jetzt sollten
also keine als eine erweiterung unseres
virtuellen handlungsspielraums
vielleicht auch unseres handlungsraum es
verstehen unsere virtuellen handlungen
sind viel vernetzter als es unsere
physischen handlung sind warum weil sie
eben unsere physischen handlungen in
raum und zeit viel stärker verortet und
auch beschränkt sind ich hatte schon
über die reibungslose geteilt des
virtuellen raumes gesprochen deswegen
ist aber dann auch die frage nach der
verantwortung zuschreibung von cani auch
komplexe einhergehend mit diesem
virtuellen immer vernetzt dann raum das
heißt wir könnten sagen dass ein
übergang von der individuellen person
zur kollektiven person zu behalten ist
also kollektive personen kennen wir alle
staaten unternehmen einige juristische
person
wo eben nicht nur personen verbünde
gedacht werden soll die person verbünde
als ein subjekt gedacht werden das gibt
es schon und die können auch haftbar
gemacht werden also ich glaube dass
diese kollektiven personen immer mehr zu
nehmen in zeiten der künstlichen
intelligenz erweitert noch durch kw
leistung
sei es die verantwortung zu schreiben
wird immer schwieriger
und das hatte ich schon
genannt also der übergang von der
individuellen zur kollektiven person ist
zentral jetzt möchte ich noch mal ein
rückblick geben auf eine statistik wir
sollten hier immer auch auf basis von
fakten argumentieren und es gibt hier
hoch interessante statistiken und zwar
auf das nutzerverhalten im internet wenn
wir jetzt sagen das internet ist ein
virtueller handlungsraum das war meine
these dann müssen wir schauen was wir
denn eigentlich so getan was wird denn
da gehandelt was sind die virtuellen
handeln im internet und wenn man jetzt
auf diese statistik schaut von statista
ich muss noch schauen kann man sie ist
ich glaube sie sind nicht mehr ganz
aktuell jedenfalls wenn wir mal hier
drauf schauen sehen wir die handlung
sind eigentlich ziemlich beschränkt
senden und empfangen von e-mails suchen
nach informationen lesen also sehr
rezepte aktivitäten weniger wirklich
aktivität natürlich ist suchen auch eine
aktivität suchen will gelernt sein über
die bedeutung des suchens in der sphäre
digitalität haben wir auch schon
gesprochen aber es ist doch ziemlich
passiv musik hören das sind alles
rezeptions handlungen und engel kann
also sagen das internet wird noch
überwiegend als instrumentelle im sinne
eines kommunikations- informations- und
unterhaltungsmedium genutzt seit der
kohlekrise wird es aber auch immer mehr
als ein interaktion sind arbeitsraum
zumindest sichtbar etwa über
videotelefonieren konferenz tun wie wir
es auch gerade jetzt tun soll dazu kommt
dass durch cloud technologien der
arbeitsplatz in den virtuellen raum
verlegt wird sodass man überaus
ubiquitär gearbeitet werden kann dieses
berühmte home office zu dem es
vielleicht auch bald ein recht ein
anrecht geben könnte das wird heiß
diskutiert
zweiter punkt der auf die nächste
sitzung schon vorweg weil es sind die
computerspiele die nicht mehr nur wie es
in den 90er jahren unter 18 jahren davor
war meistens gegen computer ausgetragen
wurden sollen immer mehr gegen andere
spielerinnen und spieler auf der ganzen
welt das heißt diese interaktion im
internet des virtuellen handlungsraum
zeigt sich ganz deutlich anhand der
computer spielen ich werde in der
nächsten sitzung dafür argumentieren
dass computerspiele nicht nur ein
unterhaltungsmedium darstellen das wäre
wieder zusehends hotel und auch
pazifistisch gedacht sind computerspiele
sind eine von kreativ mit den
möglichkeiten virtueller realität
umzugehen und deswegen nicht auch nicht
nur ästhetisch oder unterhaltungs medial
zu verstehen da möchte ich dafür
kommentieren
jetzt gibt es aktuelle forschungs
tendenzen die ich ihnen noch genauer
präsentieren möchte auch ein anknüpfen
an die letzte da hatten sie großes
interesse daran gezeigt das internet
wird immer mehr als eigene realität und
einer forschungsgegenstand er kann das
ist ein interessanter trend noch nicht
so sehr in der philosophie aber in
anderen bereichen zum beispiel der
soziologie der politikwissenschaften usw
das internet wird zum gegenstand
interdisziplinäre forschung es wird aber
auch und das finde ich besonders
spannend und es verweist darauf eine der
nächsten sitzung über die politik der
digitalität es wird zum gegenstand
politischer debatten und zuständigkeiten
hier noch mal ein blick auf das oxford
internet institute luciano für ideen ich
ob inzwischen genannt hatte der ist dort
ansässig das ist eines der ersten und
bedeutendsten forschungs institute zum
internet und zwar aus einer
interdisziplinären perspektive
hier sieht man noch mal die
forschungsgebiete
ökonomie
kulturwissenschaften politik
bildungswissenschaften ethik hier ist
tschernow florida angesiedelt
informationelle geografie
ungerechtigkeit problematik der
sicherheitspolitik und
es soziale garten die ja auch eine rolle
spielen also ihr informatik in verbund
mit soziologie hochinteressante
forschungsbereich und jetzt kam von
ihnen die frage auf wie sie mit
deutschland aus hat deutschland auch was
ähnliches zu bieten und das hat es wenn
auch erst seit jüngster zeit
es gibt das center for advanced
internets paris das ist das zentrum das
in bochum angesiedelt wird immer mehr
das ist schon angesiedelt es bietet sich
weiter können sie mal googeln chs hier
sind die selbstbeschreibung wir wollen
mit exzellenter forscher im dialog mit
der öffentlichkeit an der
menschenfreundlichen gestaltung einer
digitalen gesellschaft mittel wir setzen
uns wieder digitalen transformation in
all ihren facetten auseinander und
erproben unsere forschungsergebnisse der
praxis wir sehen also hier noch ein
starkes soziologisch politischer
aspekt aber auch die philosophie hat
hier natürlich fast zu sagen dann gibt
es noch das andere internet institute
der sogenannte weizenbaum institut
auch hier eine selbst charakterisierung
ist will ein exzellenter ort für
forschung zu den transformations- und
gestaltungsprozess des digitalen wandels
seien
selbstbestimmung und vernetzte
gesellschaft steht im zentrum
es ist vom bundesministerium für bildung
und forschung gefördert worden und mit
sitz in berlin im jahr 2017
gegründet worden
hier sieht man noch mal die mission also
die individuelle und gesellschaftliche
selbstbestimmung unter den bedingungen
der digitalisierung zu erforschen
weiterentwickeln und dauerhaft
ermöglichen die digitale transformation
soll wissenschaftlich begleitet werden
hier war auch der vorläufer des vorbild
des oxford internet institute
ja das gibt es noch an euren
entwicklungen hier noch mal kurz den
überblick über die forschungsbereiche
dieses weizenbaum instituts mensch
arbeit wissen marktwert ungleichheit
demokratie partizipation öffentlichkeit
verantwortung für tausende governance
querschnitts formate hier ist die
philosophie noch nicht so prominent
vertreten das wird sich aber mit der
zeit ändern jetzt kommen wir mal nach
bayern wo ja uns universität angesiedelt
ist hier das bayerische
forschungsinstitut für digitale
transformation
ein institut der bayerischen akademie
der wissenschaften
auch hier gibt es eine beschreibung
auch hier steht der begriff der
transformation im zentrum agiert die
gesellschaft das gemeinwohl die
verantwortung da sehen sich alle einig
und es geht so weit dass wir sogar seit
einiger zeit eine beauftragte der
bundesregierung für digitalisierung
haben sie kennen sie alle dorothee bär
beim drei jahre lang von 2018 bis 2023
staatsministerin für digitalisierung
oder auch digital staatsministerin
genannt die information habe ich wie
immer alle von wikipedia jetzt gab es
hier eine kritik das eingerichtete amt
des beauftragten für digitalisierung
verfüge über keine originäre
zuständigkeit nach der bundesregierung
sondern es sei auf die zusammenarbeit
mit dem bundesministerium
angewiesen so liege die
verantwortlichkeit digitale
infrastruktur beispielsweise
weiterhin im bundesverkehrsministerium
das finde ich auch interessant also
digitale infrastruktur wird analog
verstanden wie die straßen und
autobahnen vielleicht auch das tut netz
hoch interessant quelle wikipedia kann
man sich jetzt weitere gedanken machen
nach einer politik der digitalisierung
also läßt sich die digitale
infrastruktur im rahmen eines
verkehrsministeriums überhaupt noch
angemessen regeln wir scheinen das in
zukunft nicht mehr der fall zu sein hier
wird viel zu sehr die digitale
infrastruktur aller logisch zum
physischen verkehr betrachtet wir haben
gesehen die digitale infrastruktur
verläuft nach einer anderen raum und
zeit logik sie ist reibungslos vernetzt
die gibt es nicht diese reibungen raum
und zeit wir auf autobahnen oder aufzug
straßen also ich glaube wir brauchen
hier eine änderung in der politik
brauchen wir auch ein nationales
internet ministerium ist die frage
je nachdem wie wir das internet
verstehen wenn wir es als ein inter
einen virtuellen handlungsraum verstehen
der immer mehr lebensweltlich bedeutung
hat dann glaube ich sehr wohl das
problem ist eben nur das internet
entzieht sich einem reinen nationalen
zugriff
deswegen glaube ich müsste mir die folge
stellt brauchen wir nicht vielmehr eine
globale internet uno zwar die vereinten
nationen auch im internet ich glaube das
ist der weg weg von der nationalen
beschäftigung mit dem internet das
internet bis zur räson nicht national
wirklich festzumachen es hat immer die
tendenz nicht auszuhalten das heißt ich
glaube es sollte eine globale politische
organisation geben die sich mit dem
internet befasst wo wir vom internet
sprechen ist natürlich die wikipedia
eines der wichtigsten ja vorzeige
modelle des internets gibt es ein neues
buch die wikipedia story kann ich sehr
empfehlen untertitel biografie eines
weltwunders naja ob ein weltwunder ist
zwei mal dahin gestellt es gibt hier ein
vorwort noch von wikipedia gründer jimmy
wales kann ich sie empfehlen ich lese
mal vor die buch beschreibung niemand
wurde zum milliardär werden gibt es
nicht und doch gehört wikipedia zu den
top ten aller websites die enzyklopädie
ist weltweit ein synonym für wissen und
sie konnte sich gegen konkurrenten von
prag aus bis google durchsetzen ihre
entwicklung in deutschland nahm auf ganz
besondere weise fahrt aus wikipedia ist
soziales experiment
bedeutendes instrument der freiheit und
gleichzeitig geschlossene gesellschaft
pavel richter wikipedianer der ersten
stunde der fünf jahre in berlin die
geschäfte hinter dem wissens wiesen
führt ist dessen biografie erzählt eine
geschichte voller faszinierender
begebenheiten und auch von einigen
skandalen fehlern fakes und legendären
editier kriegen wikipedia ist eines der
spannendsten kulturphänomen und zur zeit
ich möchte dem unbedingt zustimmen und
glaube dass wir hier noch viel mehr
forschung bei wikipedia brauchen das ist
mein anfang eine historisch zu tun
soziologische geschichte ich da wir
brauchen auch eine philosophie von
wikipedia die dann im rahmen der
ips-technologie der erkenntnistheorie
angesiedelt sein wird aber ein paar
zitate aus diesem lesenswerte buch
zugleich ist wikipedia und gerade auch
die deutsche wikipedia geprägt von 1
mitunter toxischen diskussionskultur der
umgangston kann raul wir immer wieder
auch aggressiv fachleute fühlen sich oft
nicht ernst genommen ja geradezu
verachtet und einer kultur der
anonymität sehr wichtig das problem der
anonymität auch frauen sind massiv
unterrepräsentiert unter den autoren 90
prozent sind männer von menschen mit
migrationshintergrund oder ohne formale
schulbildung wollen wir gar nicht erst
sprechen wikipedia ist eine
erfolgsgeschichte mit schattenseiten die
hier nicht verschwiegen werden soll
finde ich sehr sehr löblich dass ja auch
die probleme die soziologischen probleme
angesprochen werden noch ein letztes
zitat als enzyklopädie steht wikipedia
integration der osteopathie von denen
die der raw der enzyklopädie
agritechnica und von meyers und propst
enzyklopädien sammeln nicht nur einfach
wissen sind instrumente der aufklärung
der befreiung des menschen aus seiner
selbstverschuldeten unmündigkeit wiens
der philosoph immanuel kant 1784
formulierte das war im 18 jahrhundert
ebenso revolutionär wie es das heute ist
wissen ist macht ist kein spruch aus
einem glückskeks sind versprechen und
promt zugleich ein versprechen für die
unterdrückten und benachteiligte auf
teilhabe und eine drohung gegen
diejenigen die wissen bisher
kontrolliert und den zugang zu ihm
beschränkt haben in dem wikipedia wissen
frei zur verfügung stellt und für
jedermann zugänglich macht betont ist
die machtpositionen von herrschenden von
kirchen von unternehmen nachhaltig
wissen ist ein großes geschäft und
wikipedia erschüttert die grundlagen
dieses geschäfts dem ist glaube ich sehr
zuzustimmen wie jetzt genau die
machtstrukturen hier zu sehen sind
müsste man genau untersuchen ich finde
besonders wichtig hier diesem
enzyklopädischen aspekt entwickler petit
ist eine lange tradition der aufklärung
in diesem sinne sollten an wikipedia
verstehen das führt wieder zur politik
der digitalität auf die wir auch in
einer der nächsten sitzungen genauer
eingehen
ich möchte auch nicht verschweigen die
hochschule erwähnen in stuttgart in die
das institut für digitale ethik
beherbergt hier gibt es jetzt die zehn
gebote der digital ethik diese hängt von
dieser dieser einrichtung ich möchte mal
ein paar vorlesen
akzeptieren nichts sagt das zweite gebot
das zu beobachtet wirst und deine daten
gesammelt werden
vertrauen nicht jedem mit dem du online
kontakt hast ist das gebotene maß
exakt misst deinen wird nicht anleiten
post
und nur zehn schalte hin und wieder ab
und können wir auch mal eine auszeit
das sind sicherlich
wichtige geboten nummer drei ist sollte
man noch vielleicht besonders
hervorheben glaube nicht alles was du
online zwist und informiere dich aus
verschiedenen quellen das ist sicherlich
richtig nur
diese anderen quellen aus denen man sich
informieren könnte könnten doch auch
online existieren also ich sehe hier
nicht so genau worauf das hinausläuft
und bei aller richtigkeit dieser gebote
scheinen sie mir noch zu sehr
technologisch instrumentell orientiert
zu sagen also mal ziehen zum beispiel
schalte einmal ab ganz klar natürlich
sollen sich die ganze zeit von dem motto
das ist nicht gut aber ist das wirklich
die essenz des digitalen muss man sich
fragen können wir nachher
weiterdiskutieren glaube es geht noch
ein bisschen
tiefer die problematik der digitalen
ethik darüber müssen aber dann noch
genauer diskutieren jetzt möchte ich mal
ansätze einer digitalen i dream gehen
jüngster zeit vorgebracht wurden raphael
kapoor ist einer der ersten der diesen
begriff digitale e ticket ins spiel
gebracht hat auch den philosophischen
diskurs eingebracht hat er sagt digitale
ethik oder informations engeren sinne
befasst sich mit den auswirkungen
digitale informations und
kommunikationstechnologie auf die
gesellschaft und die umwelt vor allem in
hinblick auf ethische fragen im umgang
mit dem internet also hier hat kaputt
schon gesehen die ethik der
digitalisierung nicht die ethik der
digitalität er verwendete begriff der
digitalität nicht die dreht sich vor
allem um das internet das internet wird
hier auch schon als eine art
handlungsraum bestimmt themen sie schutz
der privatsphäre
informationsüberflutung internet sucht
die digitale trennung zwischen arm und
reich überwachung und robotik treten für
ihn besonders ins zentrum ich bin mir
nicht ganz sicher ob internet sucht
wirklich ein thema digitaler ethik ist
das nicht ein problem der psychologie
ist darüber kann man auch nur
diskutieren ich bin hier ein bisschen
skeptisch wie sie alle wissen die
kernaussage zielt nach kabul darauf ab
dass ethische reflexion dazu beitragen
können sollen sozial orientiert und
umweltfreundliche lösung für die
herausforderungen des digitalen
zeitalters zu erarbeiten und diese auch
gefunden werden können das ist
sicherlich richtig jetzt muss man sich
nur eben überlegen was ist überhaupt das
digitale zeitalter
was sind die herausforderungen gut hier
hat er schon einige genannt sind dass
alle herausforderungen dann gibt es noch
viele gedanken die man noch weiter
verfolgen kann ich möchte auch noch auf
dieses buch hier hinweisen digitale
ethik das ist aus dieser diesem
hochschule der medien
dieser digitalen
tätig
kooperationen hervorgegangen leben in
vernetzten behalten hier zitiere ich
auch mal kurz als erweiterung der ethik
analysiert die digitale ethik also
welche legitimen handlungsoptionen sich
aus der entwicklung dem einsatz und der
anwendung digitaler technologien ergeben
sie kann hierzu auf das bereits zur
verfügung stehen die analytische
instrumentarium der ethik zurückgreifen
sie will damit jedoch auf keinen fall
die bestehenden verhältnisse bloßstellte
interview dort wo es sinnvoll und
möglich ist ihre theoretische
analytisches erwägungen in die praxis
überführt die digitale ethiker zuziehe
den menschen zu einem
reflexionsfähigkeit gestalter seiner
bild zu befähigen
die kunst bahre haltungen entwickelt und
sich auf dieser basis verantwortlich in
der digitalität verhält die grundfrage
der digital-logic also welche ethischen
positionen kommen hierbei und gerade
auch mit blick auf ihre praktische
anwendbarkeit im alltag zu tragen das
finde ich alles sehr sehr sinnvoll
einerseits auf die bisherigen ethischen
mode litt zurückzugreifen und nicht nur
analog dazu
voranzuschreiten zum auch ganz kritisch
zu fragen was sich hier verändert
also das ist sehr löblich hier ist der
begriff der digitalität genannt der wird
aber in diesem buch soweit ich sehe
nicht extra analysiert hier wird er wohl
synonym zu digitalen
lebenswelt gebraucht hier könnte man
noch weiter ansetzen aber ansonsten
finde ich diese unternehmung sehr
sinnvoll möchte auch nicht verschweigen
das buch von julian nida-rümelin und
natalie breitenfeld digitaler humanismus
eine ethik für das zeitalter der
künstlichen genc kennen sie bestimmt er
lehrte an der
ludwig-maximilians-universität ist jetzt
aber emeritiert worden hier ein zitat
möchte ich ihnen auch vorlesen jenseits
apokalyptischer untergangsszenarien und
technizistischen lösungs hoffnung gibt
es den mittleren weg der bewahrung und
verbesserung der menschlichen
lebensbedingungen durch den kulturell
sozial und politisch kontrollierten
einsatz technologischer möglichkeiten
die menschliche existenz form ist nicht
an ex technische entwicklung vielmehr
ist es die große herausforderung unserer
verantwortlichkeit die digitalisierung
so zu gestalten dass sie zur
humanisierung der welt beiträgt also
hier ganz im sinne des humanismus
möchten ihr handeln
digitalisierung verstehen digitale
humanismus setzt diese ideologisierung
digitaler technologien ich hatte schon
ray kurzweil
genannt und diese idee der singularität
dagegen möchte dieser digitale
humanismus eine haltung der nüchternheit
setzt die alle technologien der
vergangenheit sind auch die digitalen
ambivalent irgendwo ein automat ist ein
automatismus der humanisierung oder der
erlösung vielmehr hängt es von den
konkreten formen ihren nutzern ab ob
diese menschen freundlich oder
menschenfeindlich ist es geht also um
die nutzer
digitale humanismus plädiert für eine
instrumentelle haltung gegenüber der
digitalisieren was kann ökonomisch
sozial und kulturell nutzen und wo
lauern gefahren also hier die
digitalisieren als ein werkzeug was
sinnvoll gebraucht werden kann das ist
nach jan in berlin der humanistischen
ansatz für eine ethik die
digitalisierung ja ich habe hier wie
immer einige kritik anzubringen
natürlich finde ich diese optimistische
idee sehr löblich ganz klar muss
digitalisierung und menschenfreundlich
menschlich gestartet werden nur habe ich
ein problem mit dieser instrumentellen
haltung gegenüber der digitalisierung da
setze ich den begriff der digitalität
entgegen ich glaube digitalisierung wird
oder ist immer mehr kein bloßes
instrument sondern ein lebens wirklicher
faktor das heißt hier bleibt
digitalisierung immer noch äußerlich als
ein objekt und ich glaube da kommen wir
nicht drum herum digitalisierung
vielmehr zu integrieren sie in der
virtuellen realität und wenn wir das tun
dann wird sie sicherlich auch
humanistisch verstehbar sein nur eben
nicht mehr in instrumentellen sinne sind
dann eröffnen sich uns ganz neue
handlungsspielräume wie eben auch der
virtuelle handlungsraum des internets
also meine kritik daran nicht die
journalistische ansatz dass wir nicht
sehr sehr gut meine kritik ist die
unterschätzung der realität im see der
virtuellen realität
der entwicklung die mit der
digitalisierung einhergehen und eben
auch die unterschätzung der neuen
möglichkeiten aber natürlich auch
herausforderung die sich dadurch für uns
stellen jetzt gibt es seit einiger zeit
eine charta der digitalen grundrechte
der europäischen union
auf die ich auch schon hingewiesen hatte
die sie auf sich im internet anschauen
können und zwar
ist es versteht sich diese karte als ein
politisches manifest gestalt eines
gesetzes ähnlichen text sie enthält
neben vorschlägen für künftige
grundrechte auch starts bestimmen und
möglichen aufträge an den europäischen
gesetzgeber die alle zusammen die größe
der herausforderung um reisen und die
bedeutung der bürgerrechte im digitalen
zeitalter
betonen soll man es geht um
grundrechte digitale grundrechte die
hier gefordert werden angesichts der
digitalen transformation
wir würden auch die angeborene würde
betont aber auch die zunehmende
digitalisierung
die eben vor keinem bereich mehr halt
macht jesus
machtverschiebungen gesprochen
eine zivilgesellschaftliche debatte
ja und auch davon dass der technische
fortschritt im dienst der menschheit zu
stehen hat das gift wieder an den
digitalen humanismus an von dem auch
julian nida-rümelin gesprochen hat die
gestaltung der digitalen welt muss eine
europäische aufgabe sein und es soll nur
im europäischen verbund gelingen
freiheit gerechtigkeit und solidarität
in 21 ländern zu erhalten hier muss man
erst was es überhaupt mit digitaler welt
gemeint dieser begriff wird einfach so
ins spiel gebracht der müsste genauer
geklärt werden solange nicht diese
begrifflichen grundlagen klar sind wird
es schwierig einen
katalog von digitalen rechten rechten im
digitalen zeitalter aufzustellen genau
so scheint es mir problematisch zu sein
ist nur im europäischen verbund zu
diskutieren man kann zwar sagen europa
ist der ursprung der aufklärung aber das
ist eigentlich dieser entwicklung des
internets ganze dem gesetz das internet
ist nicht nur auf einzelne regionen
wie europa beschränkt soll das internet
ist eine weltweite globale
herausforderung deswegen waren mich
gleich global im sinne der vereinten
nationen oder etwas ähnlichem darauf
geht man dann noch genauer in einer der
folgenden sitzung ein wenn es um die
politik der digitalen text aber im
grunde natürlich sehr löblich ein
solches unterfangen
und jetzt ist hier auch noch ein
interessantes zitat es soll das
fundament einer rechtsstaatlichen
ordnung im digitalen zeitalter
geschaffen werden das digitale soll
nicht als quelle der angst als chance
auf ein gutes leben einer globalen
zukunft erfasst werden das finde ich
sehr überzeugend also nicht als
bedrohung sind sie als eine chance und
auch diese globale dimension die hier
jetzt wieder stärker hervorgehoben wird
erscheint mir sehr angemessen zu sein
natürlich muss man sich jetzt fragen wie
leben angesichts des digitalen
auszusehen hat geht es um eine digitale
lebenswelt usw das muss man noch genauer
natürlich untersuchen und jetzt geht es
hier die um die recht freiheiten und
grundsätze die jetzt hier genannt werden
möchte jetzt mal ein paar der verändern
partikel artikel 1 cent irrt natürlich
am deutschen grundgesetz die würde des
menschen ist auch im digitalen zeitalter
unantastbar sie ist zu achten und zu
schützen kein technischer entwicklung
darf sie beeinträchtigen
interessant ist bei diesen artikeln dass
es nur darunter einen diskussions
kontext gibt der sich auch anschauen
können da können sie auch mitdiskutieren
war sie ihn sehr empfehlen wäre dann
immer gewartet was ist das
überzeugendste argument der diskussion
ein jürgen prima ob es jetzt sein
wirklicher name oder ein pseudonym ist
einmal ganz dahin gestellt
jetzt zum vergleich die formulierung im
grundgesetz die würde des menschen ist
unantastbar sie zu achten und zu
schützen ist verpflichtung aller
staatlichen gewalt die formulierung in
dieser version stellt damit insbesonders
im zweiten satz ein rückschritt dar da
die begrifflichkeit der verpflichtung
fehlt also hier fehlt einfach die
verpflichtungen und gegensatz zum
artikel 1 grundgesetz also dem auto dem
kommentator ist dieser artikel zu
schwach formulieren diese digitalen
karte die ece als abkürzung ja kann man
trefflich darüber streiten artikel 2 der
die freiheit betrifft jeder mensch hat
ein recht auf freie information
kommunikation ist beinhaltet das
persönliche recht auf nichtwissen hier
finde ich den alten satz besonders
interessant das persönliche recht auf
nicht wissen im digitalen zeitalter
jetzt hat luciano florida vom oxford
internet institute dazu stellung
genommen nicht direkt zu der digitalen
karte aber er hat selbst sich gedanken
gemacht ob es so was mit ein recht auf
nichtwissen geben kann rahmen seiner
ethik der information er sagt wir
erleben eine substanzielle aushöhlung
des rechts auf nichtwissen in einer
immer reibungslos funktionierenden infos
fähre verliert die behaupten man habe
nichts gewusst angesichts von leicht
vorhersehbaren ereignissen und kaum
ignoriert barren sachsen zunehmend an
glaubwürdigkeit also hier ist flori die
ganz entgegen gesetzt und ich würde
florida auch zustimmen wenn wir alle
freien zugang zum wissen haben dann
haben wir damit nicht nur ein recht die
werden nur die rechte diskutiert sondern
wir haben auch eine pflicht zum wissen
also ich würde und darauf komme ich
später noch gerne diese ganzen
grundrechte digital art ergänzen einen
pflichtenkatalog zumindest hier stärke
die pflichten entspricht und ich glaube
wirklich floride zeigt hier einen
wichtigen punkt wie es mit der
moralischen verantwortung aussieht wir
können uns immer weniger auf unseren
nichtwissen berufen vielleicht können
wir noch vorgeben das hätten ja auch
fällt news sein können aber es steht uns
immer frei alternative quellen
heranzuziehen die wir eben auch im
internet finden internet ist eben auch
immer noch ein informations und das wird
gewaltige konsequenzen so behaupte ich
auch in der rechtsprechung haben wenn
wir viel mehr wissen können in zukunft
und dementsprechend auch viel mehr
berücksichtigen müssen und viel haftbar
wären das also wirklich ein ganz
konkretes angewandtes ethisches problem
artikel 3 gleichheit jeder mensch hat
das recht auf eine gleichberechtigte
teilhabe der digitalen sphäre
es gilt das in der europäischen
grundrechte-charta formulierte
diskriminierungsverbot
ja die verbindung von automatisierten
verfahren darf nicht dazu führen dass
menschen vom zugang zu gütern
dienstleistungen oder von der teilhabe
am gesellschaftlichen leben
ausgeschlossen werden dies gilt
insbesondere im bereich
gesundheitsschutz für elementare
lebensrisiken recht auf arbeit recht auf
wohnung recht auf bewegungsfreiheit und
bei justiz und sei also hier werden
wieder sehr viele rechte gefordert ich
kann man sich jetzt natürlich fragen wie
ist diese digitale sphäre von der hier
im ersten satz die rede ist genau zu
verstehen
also das wäre meine kritik hier müssen
erst die grundbegriffe geklärt werden
bevor man hier sich an die arbeit machen
kann richtig zu fordern und ich muss
auch immer ein vergleich hergestellt
werden zur analogen
vorbildern wie sie im grundgesetz
verlegt werden das grundgesetzt betrifft
sicherlich auch die digitale sphäre aber
sie das grundgesetz reflektiert diese
beginnen
zentrale begriffe sind also hier
philosophisch nicht geklärt eine
digitale ethik so meine überzeugung muss
sich jedoch zunächst diese kompatible
genauer anschauen und zwar philosophisch
und sie klären erst auf dieser basis
können wir dann daher gehen und eine
ethik oder auch eine politik der
digitalität entwickeln artikel 7
privatsphäre vertraulichkeit und
datenschutz
finde ich hier besonders den vierten
punkt wichtig jeder mensch hat das recht
auf totalen neuanfang dieses recht
findet seine grenzen in den berechtigten
informationsinteresse der öffentlichkeit
also hier wird implizit
vorausgesetzt dass ein mensch auch eine
digitale existenz haben kann das finde
ich sehr sehr interessant er hat eine
leerung man wieder ist es ihr richtiger
name ist die frage geschrieben
ich würde es gut finden wenn der begriff
digital ein neues land genauer definiert
wird wie genau kann man den neuanfang
wie wird garantiert dass persönliche
daten wirklich aus dem internet gelöscht
werden stichwort das internet vergisst
nichts oft kommt es vor dass daten von
der öffentlichkeit stehenden personen
nach jahren mit erscheinen dass leute
durch die daten dieser menschen und dies
kann keine nachweisen kann wie kann ich
sicherstellen dass ein von ihr
hochgeladen das bild welches ich lösche
nicht von jemandem gespeichert wurde ein
digitaler neuanfang scheint für mich
schon fast unmöglich zu sein da jeder
ein recht auf privatsphäre hat kann man
handys nicht überwachen oder
kontrollieren und das kann missbraucht
werden ich will entscheiden können was
ich preisgebe doch wenn das nicht zu 100
prozent garantiert werden kann glaube
ich nicht ein digitaler hat fahren ja
ich glaube es auch nicht so ganz das
hängt einfach mit dieser logik des
internets zu sein sie haben das web al
kaida im internet als gesehen der eine
der letzten sitzungen wo ich zeigen
konnte wie eine alte seite des
philosophie departments lmu münchen
plötzlich zum leben erweckt wird kommt
her wir wissen nicht was gespeichert
wird sei es durch das internet sei es
durch privatpersonen die sich daten auf
ihrem computer lagen und ist dann nach
belieben wieder einspeisen können sie
internet also ich habe hier so meine
zweifel darüber können diskutieren
artikel 10 freier zugang jeder mensch
hat das recht auf einen freien gleichen
zukunft mit dem informationsdienst
zugang ohne dafür auf grundlegende
rechte 40 zu müssen dieser zugang ist
flächen denkt angemessen und ausreichend
zu gewährleisten jeder mensch hat das
recht auf eine nicht personalisierte
nutzung digitaler angebote einschränken
dürfen nur auf gesetzlicher grundlage
stattfinden hier stimmig sie dazu also
hier geht es jetzt um die
etablierung um die ja
mitmachen eines virtuellen handlungsraum
der eben immer auch flächendeckend und
nicht personalisierte möglich sein
sollte damit sollte man auch vorbild
nicht kommerzialisiert das ist auch noch
ein ganz wichtiger punkt ja jetzt kann
man weiter fragen wir haben dass wir mit
einer ethik der digitalisierung zu tun
hatten vorigen oder mit einer digitalen
ethik jetzt möchte ich einen schritt
weiter gehen ganz im sinne des themas
der vorlesung und folgen das ist eine
ehrliche digitale kate mit der
digitalisierung die differenz hatte ich
ja schon genauer vorgestellt eine diät
der digitalität muss auf die virtuelle
realität der digitalität reflektieren
und sich von bos instrument allen
zugängen zu digitalisieren ab bis das
greift in meinen augen nicht weit genug
sie muss zuerst bestimmen was eine
virtuelle handlung und was ein
virtueller akteur ist vor behauptet über
moralische dinge gesprochen werden kann
eine ethik der digitalität muss das
internet wie schon oft gesagt habe als
einen virtuellen handlungsraum bestimmt
und dessen ethischen herausforderungen
identifizieren sie muss ethische regeln
formulieren die für einen virtuellen
akteur mit virtueller aktuellen im
virtuellen handelsraum geltend zwar
eine ethik der digitalität muss also
neben digitalen rechten von denen wir
gerade einige diskutiert hatten auch
einen katalog digitaler pflichten
formulieren das geht jetzt als
einrichtung einer der onkologischen
idealer pflicht geht hier stellt sich
jetzt weiter die frage welche ethischen
ansatz für die digitalität am
geeignetsten ist ist es die tugend ethik
die der ontologie die pflicht tätig oder
der konsequenz l ist also ein ethischer
ansatz der auf die folgen achtet die mit
handlungen koch im virtuellen raum
einhergehen das ist eine spannende frage
stellt sich also wenn wir jetzt auf die
genetik reflektieren die frage nach
spezifisch digitalen kugel häufig wird
die medienkompetenz ihre genannt ich bin
aber der meinung dass medienkompetenz
nicht technologisch oder instrumentell
verstanden werden sollte soll im sinne
einer lebensweltlichen totalen tun also
medienkompetenz wenn er sie jetzt als
digitale tugend begreifen sollte nicht
nur wie es häufig der fall ist inhalten
wie gehe ich mit den technischen
objekten instrumenten um wie häufig
verwende ich ein smartphone das halte
ich so zu äußern das trifft nicht den
kern der probleme habe es muss die frage
betreffen wie ich im alltag in der
lebenswelt digital oder auch virtuelle
möglichkeiten nutzt also wie ich sie
integrieren in meinen alltag wenn ihr
digitale trugen zeichnet sich dadurch
aus also die digitalisierung als einen
lebensweltlichen faktor versteht und
nicht nur als ein instrument ist mir
ganz wichtig es geht also um die frage
wie ich digitale technik so eins mit
setzen kann da sie zur erweiterung
virtuell virtueller realität beitragen
kann das ist wieder diesem rein
instrumentellen verständnis entgegen
gesetzt
digitalisierung soll neue möglichkeiten
eröffnen realität eröffnet und dies
sollen zum guten natürlich verwendet
werden dh digitale tugend bedeutet den
übergang von der digitalisierung die vor
allem technologisch die instrumental
verstanden ist zur digitalität der
virtuellen realität zu vollziehen das
ist die typen das ist eigentlich
medienkompetenz die dinge die
technologie nicht nur als hilfs oder
spiel mit ihm zu verwenden sondern
dadurch meine möglichkeiten meine realen
möglichkeiten erweitern und neue
dimension eröffnet der begriff der
digitalität ist so gesehen bereits
normativ im gegensatz zum begriff der
digitalisierung und verweist so auf
diese ethik der digitalität digitalität
ist der gelungene die gelungene
integration digitaler möglichkeiten im
sinne virtuelle realität
ich möchte noch ein ausgegeben und zwar
auf das digitale gewohnt schon böse zwei
mal ganz konkret werden wenn es die
digitalisierung geht was ist jetzt
digital digital gut digital gut ist man
sagen dass das wenige was den virtuellen
handlungsraum durch digitale medien
vergrößert das heißt was unsere
virtuelle freiheit stärken die gibt's
ein paar beispiele open access freeware
kann kommerzielle globale
bildungsangebote wie zb
teilweise wikipedia
barrierefreiheit für menschen
unterschiedlichster situation
unterschiedlichsten alters sollte der
digitalen raum zugänglich sein
unmittelbar zugelegt und jeder und jede
der dazu beiträgt gut in meinen augen
etwas digital gutes weiter die grenz-
und kultur überschreitende kooperation
also grenzen überwinden zu anderen
sprache zu anderen kulturen und auch das
weiterspinnen am öffentlichen netz also
informationen ins internet so
einschleusen so einspielen dass es den
bestehenden kontext erweitert und nicht
im sinne von privaten netzwerken oder
gar den daad mit dass eine gegenwelt
dazu schafft also der begriff der
öffentlichkeit scheint mir auch ganz
wichtig auf eine normativ eticket
getarnt sind es gut jetzt möchte ich die
schattenseiten betrachten wir hatten der
letzten sitzung des partners behandelt
digital böses in meinen augen das wenige
was den virtuellen handlungsraum
einschränkt was als unsere virtuelle
freiheit beschränkt einschränken auch
hier ein paar beispiele die reduktion
des virtuellen subjekts zur bluse
kommerziell verwertbaren metadaten als
die ökonomisierung die zu starke
ökonomisierung die vorhand behandelt uns
nur als objekt als informationen zur
unternehmens steigern gewinnsteigerung
maxime ihr fehle der datenschutz die
abkapselung von inter netzen also die
entgegengesetzte tendenz zum
öffentlichen weiterspinnen am globalen
jetzt dieses zu stark private ist die
abkapselung dann die aktivitäten dort
nicht dass
regellos und natürlich auch höchst
illegal ist und zwar einen geschützten
raum geben bedeutet das heißt jeder
tritt in stuxnet ist potenziell
problematisch sie wissen es kann sein
dass auf ihrem computer dann gewisse
daten einfach so abgespeichert werden
welche cookies oder ich weiß nicht was
dann machen sie sich gegebenenfalls
strafbar wenn diese daten die ohne ihr
wissen auf ihren pc landen leben illegal
sind weiterer punkt ist
identitätsdiebstahl gibt es natürlich
auch im analogen raum identitäts die
bestand aber eben lang nicht so leicht
deswegen die schwächung der internet
infrastruktur und des vertrauens in sie
hier sind hecking
zensur domain schweren politische art
und fake news zu empfehlen ist gibt es
natürlich auch im analogen raum habe wie
auch eben im sinne des
identitätsdiebstahls lange nicht so
reibungslos und soja wird
sie könnte man diese punkte noch weit
weiter erweitern sie ist kein ende in
sicht er wird uns auch die zukunft neue
formen des virtuellen titan bösen zeigen
leider wenn ihr möchte ich jetzt noch
abschließend auf luciano florian sei die
fx of information eingeht weil flori die
als andere ersten den begriff des
künstlichen böse die fischer evil
geprägt hat angesichts vor allem
künstliche intelligenz und überhaupt der
aktuellen heraus vorlesen morgen
frequency ist beschrieb fans des seins
mehr konfrontiert bei wiese wurden
zählen wales das im bachelor neue medien
morgen innocent da ist begrüßt die andré
lenz delay traffic über computer based
manager ritus in den mittel gekürzt
software ist noch voll kompatibel mit
programm stolzen use with the patients
and increased
riskiert die gesamte liebe alte tatort
kein softie wird dies kann man sich
freuen ist es sind das wirklich fälle
des bösen florida argumentiert dass ich
eine dritte art dritte kategorie von
bösen ins spiel kommt weder das bloß
natürlich also wie naturkatastrophen
oder büros menschliche also wie zb morde
sondern etwas was durch die neuen medien
mit dem spiel kommt er spricht hier von
otti fischer agency cummings fischers to
create the possibility that the creators
maybe normale jacqueline charts auf
vor der miss behavior and the us will
die linke dennoch verließ im playboy und
controller just imagine und die
situation nur bereit im handel die us
science and technology advance for
nature more work at the same time green
create a new form of anti phishing
entscheidend ist hier dass die er
spricht von handlungen das kann jetzt in
frage stellen die operation von
künstlichen akteure mit künstlichen
intelligenzen wie roboter dass die immer
autonomer werden und nicht mehr nur
logisch sein motiv also zieht er eine
ableitung
auf die hersteller zurückgeführt werden
könne so eine notwendige kette wenn das
der fall wäre eine lückenlose
rückverfolgung im sinne einer logischen
reduktion auf die hersteller wir hätten
natürlich die hersteller tiefe angst
über die aktivitäten die da passiert
sind aber das sagt er sei immer weniger
der fall das heißt wir können in der
frage nach dem schuldigen nicht mehr den
hersteller die herstellerin ins feld
führen und genau so wird es auch in
zukunft sein auch die fischer ages media
council for action comic no human body
by nature can be considered responsible
niederfeld kategorie of the witch ich
find s oliver spannende frage gibt es ja
einen dritten fall des bösen neben dem
menschlichen und dem natürlichen
lösen damit möchte ich für heute
belassen und einen ausblick geben auf
die nächste sitzung nicht bevor ich noch
zwei weitere zitate ganz kurz hier nur
genannt habe er sagt ganz am ende bobby
fischer ist deutsche bier growing namens
wepad andere kapitel die new
yorker gemeldet also in zukunft dieses
problem des künstlichen bösen durch dass
die grenzen immer virulenter werden wir
sollten das nicht unter den ethischen
teppich kehren solches sondern sollten
diese problematik stellen genau das ist
alles in dieser info sphäre der fall er
bringt ja als beispiele für solche bösen
handlungen akteure viren und bots die
eben solche künstlichen bösen taten
verbringen kann jetzt geht es aber wie
gesagt zum ausblick zur nächsten sitzung
am 14 januar
hier wird die ästhetik der digitalität
zumindest der erste teil im zentrum
stehen und anhand der problematik
virtueller kunst sie kennen alle diese
nun von jackies
heftis dann zentrum stehen dass falls
nicht werde ich darauf genauer eingehen
als geht und virtuelle kunstwerke dann
geht es um die ästhetik der künstlichen
intelligenz
also was kann künstliche begann sich
werde auf eine neue komposition sie
kennen das von beethoven die fortführung
einer symphonie von ihnen durch kürzen
fliegens eingehen oder auf künstliche
gemälde von kontingenten in der
übernächsten sitzung im zweiten teil zu
ästhetik der digitalität geht es dann um
die ästhetik der computerspiele die sehr
interessant die dimension von virtueller
realität fiktion illusion und
simulationen ein verhältnis ja dann
bedanke mich für die aufmerksamkeit und
bin gespannt auf die diskussion